bienvenidos a la presentación de las
restas de nivel 4 y vamos a comenzar con
algunos problemas nuestro primer
problema es 33.000 220 a esto le voy a
restar 399
aquí vamos a hacerlo muy similar a como
se hizo en el nivel 3 vamos a pedir
prestado vamos a verificar que todos los
dígitos sean mayores los de arriba a los
de abajo y claramente vemos que este 0
no es mayor que 9 y esto es un problema
porque no podemos quitarle algo pequeño
algo muy grande porque quedaría en
cantidades negativas
vamos a revisar entonces que estas
cantidades sean mayores el cero no es
mayor que el 9 que tenemos que hacer
pues pedirle prestado al 211 para hacer
crecer este cero y convertirlo a 10 así
que bueno algunos dicen que no es
prestar un 1 sino prestar 10 unidades
porque estas son decenas entonces por
simplicidad vamos a decir que vamos a
tomar prestado un 1 y vamos a tomar este
0 y lo vamos a transformar ahora en 10
ya que pedimos una unidad prestada al 2
y el 2 se convierte ahora en un 1 porque
pues pedimos prestado una unidad para el
bueno no los quiero confundir demasiado
vamos a ver que esta va a ser la
mecánica que vamos a trabajar tomamos un
2 del 2 tomamos un 1 para convertir el 0
en 10 aquí tenemos el 1 y seguimos
revisando vemos que este 1 es más chico
que el 9 tenemos que pedir prestado
nuevamente ahora tomo del 2 voy a
tomarlo tomar una unidad y ese 11 uno se
convierte ahora en un 11
así que tenemos 10 es mayor que 9 11 es
mayor que 9 pero nuevamente el 1 es más
pequeño que el 3 y tenemos que pedir
prestado de nuevo es un poquito
complicado esto quizás debí decirles que
íbamos a tener que pedir mucho prestado
pero bueno vamos a hacer lo mismo este
uno se convierte en 11 y el 3 al que le
pedimos prestado va a convertirse en un
creo que ya terminamos revisamos 10
mayor que 9 11 mayor que 9 11 mayor que
32 mayor que nada 3 es mayor que nada
ahora sí podemos hacer la resta 10 menos
9 111 menos 9 son 211 menos 3 van a ser
8 aquí escribimos el 82 menos nada es 2
es menos nada queda 3 y nuestro
resultado es 32 1821 así que lo que
realmente hace más difícil esto que en
una resta normal es el saber cómo hacer
o cómo hacer o pedir prestado para tener
los números de arriba más grandes que
los de abajo yo estoy haciendo esto de
una manera quizás diferente de como
ustedes lo aprendieron en la clase pero
me parece que esto es más fácil hacer
todo el préstamo en un solo momento para
tener ya todas las cantidades listas
vamos a ver otro ejemplo ahora tengo
25.000
a esto le vamos a restar 578
bueno aquí vamos a hacer exactamente lo
mismo comenzamos a revisar que este
dígito sea mayor que el de abajo en este
caso vemos que el 3 es más pequeño que
el 8 tenemos que pedir prestado de
manera que el 3 ahora se va a convertir
en 13
y por supuesto el 3 al que le pedimos
prestado se va a convertir en un 2
tomamos un 1 de este 3 para convertirlo
aquí el 3 en 1313 es más grande que el 8
pero ahora el 2 es más pequeño que el 7
pedimos prestado convertimos el 12 y
ahora este 6 al que le quitamos un 1 se
va a convertir en un 5 13 es más creo
que 8 12 mayor que 75 es igual que 5 así
que podemos tener una resta exacta que
55 va a ser 0 mientras el número de
arriba sea igual o mayor no tenemos
problema todas las demás no hay problema
para hacer la resta si que es 13 menos 8
va a ser 5 12 menos 7
va a ser 555 va a ser 05 - nada queda 52
menos nada queda 2 queda 25.000 55
así que aquí este ejemplo no estuvo tan
complicado pero vamos a hacer otro que
quizás los confunda un poquito más
porque la parte del préstamo no es tan
fácil vamos a tener aquí 37 mil
002 o sea 37 mil 2 - 155
vamos a hacer lo mismo el 2 vemos que es
más chico que el 5 tenemos que pedir
prestado para convertirlo en un 12 pero
que creen es un 0 no puedo quitarle algo
a un 0 algunos dicen que es posible pero
para mí me parece algo confuso porque en
el 0 no hay nada vemos el junto hay otro
0 tampoco le puedo pedir prestado pero
aquí hay un 7 en lugar de pedir prestado
un 1 al 0 lo que voy a hacer es pedir
prestado un 1 del 700 de toda esta
cantidad 700 que es 700 menos 1 pues nos
va a quedar 699
699 ahora hacemos la revisión quitamos
esto revisamos ahora si el 12 es mayor
que 5 el 9 es mayor que el 5 el 9 es
mayor que el 16 es mayor que 0 o que
nada 13 es mayor que nada ahora podemos
hacer la resta doce menos cinco va a ser
79 menos 5 queda 49 menos uno va a ser
86 menos nada 63 - nada queda 3 quedamos
con 36 mil 847 y hemos terminado con
este problema creo que no está hay
tiempo para que podamos hacer otro más
tengo aquí tres mil 201
- digamos que va a ser 500
hacemos lo mismo uno es más chico que el
dos tenemos que pedir prestado para
convertir esto en un once juntos tenemos
un cero no lo puedo hacer pero aquí voy
a pedir prestado al 2020 menos uno y va
a quedar 19 aquí escribo el 19
y revisamos tengo el 11 que es mayor que
el 29 es mayor que 0 está bien 1 es
menor que el 5 tengo que pedir prestado
para esto convertirlo en 11 y el 3 se va
a convertir en un 2 ahora sí puedo hacer
la resta y revisó de nuevo todas las
cantidades de arriba son más grandes que
las de abajo
así que hacemos la resta 11 menos 29 9
-0 9 11 menos 5 queda 62 menos nada me
va a quedar el 2
el resultado es 2 mil 699 así que esta
es nuestro resultado 3200 1 - 502 igual
a 2 mil 699 creo que ustedes están
listos para hacer sus propias restas
recuerden de hacer primero sus préstamos
al principio para asegurarse que todos
los números de arriba sean mayores que
los números de abajo y puedan hacer una
resta como ustedes la conocen espero que
se diviertan con esto nos vemos